I hate it when girls are like oh my gosh
my crush doesn't even know that I exist
like girl my crush doesn't even exist
sounds like Selena Gomez is ready for
romance again now all she has to do is
find a guy I think it's empowering when
you're able to do things on your own
self makes the confession in her latest
Tick Tock video I hate it when girls are
like oh my gosh my crush doesn't even
know that I exist like girl my crush
doesn't even exist so yeah sells Crush
count zero but she did admit back in
December her very first crush was
actually a fellow Disney star did you is
that your did you have a crush on cold
yes I did
what
[Applause]
yeah Selena poking fun at her love life
is nothing new in fact she's made a
whole bunch of tick tock videos about
the challenges of being a single gal
last time I was single I was 24 and the
dating pool was everyone and now it's
like a shallow puddle of age-appropriate
men who are old and gross and I don't
want to do that I'm going out tonight so
hide your man not because I want them
but because I don't want to see a
singular man on my outing I mean
oh
I love your personality in the past cell
made it clear dating not exactly a
priority but seems like things have now
changed oh my goodness A source told E.T
earlier this week Selena's in an era of
self-care she's dating and open to love
she is focused on maintaining her health
while still being attentive to her fans
Selena has been going to therapy leaning
on her friends and family and keeping
her Circle close it's important just to
remain positive I'm at that age where I
feel like that's what matters is making
sure I'm healthy and people are happy
that I love most recently Selena was
linked to The Chainsmokers Drew Taggart
the pair was spotted on a couple of
dates but ultimately self set the record
straight on her Instagram story when she
clarified I'm single I think it's nice
to have a little bit something to myself
before Drew Selena dated the weekend and
of course Justin Bieber on and off for
several years and though they split in
2018 and he married Haley Bieber shortly
after the drama just dust never stops I
accidentally laminated my brows too much
yeah rumors of a feud between Haley and
Selena sparked earlier this month after
Selena shared that video Kylie Jenner
posted this snap of her brows and a
close-up pic of Haley's brows causing
fans to speculate Kylie and Haley were
making fun of Selena things all came to
a head when this Cliff resurfaced online
Haley gagging At The Mention Of Selena's
BFF Taylor Swift on draft of Mike
Hollywood's top Stars Face-Off in a
one-on-one rap battle full of the
meanest lyrics about a celebrity since
Taylor Swift's last album
a defended Taylor in the comments but
shortly after announced she needed to
take a step back I'm going to be taking
a second from social media because
it's this is a little silly
and I'm 30 I'm too old for this so
but I love you guys so much
so since returned online keeping things
light and keeping us laughing girl my
crush doesn't even exist
[Music]
thank you